Hello internet,
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan
We're the Slow Mo Guys and as usual Dan,
we're about to make a right mess.
Why's that?
Go-GURT challenged us
to do whatever it takes
to get every last drop of Go-GURT
out of one of these tubes,
which honestly, very easy.
Nailed it.
So if you like the video,
please feel free to subscribe--
Wait, wait, that's not
the video, obviously.
What do you mean?
Well, one, it's too easy.
Okay. What do you suggest?
Escalate it.
A thousand tubes of Go-GURT,
all in one go, empty 'em.
Alright. Yeah.
Thankfully we have DIY expert
and Go-GURT enthusiast,
Bob Vila, who's got an
immense delivery for us.
It's a thousand tubes of Go-GURT .
Woah
Hey guys,
I'm not even going to ask
what you're gurting into.
Well, I think you're going to need these,
whatever happens.
Probably for the best.
Get to safety.
Okay.
Thanks Bob.
10 out of 10 on the pun now, I like it.
Alright. Let's load this up, Daniel.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
I think you should be
close. You should be there.
Here?
We'll aim everything.
Just point the tubes this way.
The Go-Hurts this way, all right.
Happy days.
I always like it
when a company wants us
to show off their product
by destroying it.
Stay away from this.
All right, Dan, you wanna
give us a little test
of our quick release system?
Make sure it works
before we get out there.
Pull the safety pin out
and I've got this cord here.
Give this a yank.
Flip! It works.
Yeah.
That works.
That is going to go down like a,
well, like a ton.
Yeah.
All right, let's get that weight in.
Okay.
Raise her up.
Guide me in?
Yup.
Keep it coming in.
Good technique. Are you easing it,
easing it.
Alright, bring it up.
Yup.
That's down. That's down.
Give me the up signal please.
Up signal.
Thank you.
Look at you.
Give me the signal, give me the signal.
What are you doing with
your life right now?
Give me the signal, that's it.
Look at this.
All right.
Good tech is there.
Alright, Dan, thoughts?
I'm kinda scared.
Kinda scared?
By kinda,
I mean very scared.
You're very close to that.
Okay.
You ready?
Yeah.
Oh man!
Hmm. Well it bounced.
So it looks to me like
we need to put less.
I think maybe if we just
do like thin covering.
Yeah.
So we got less Go-Gurt.
We've got a heavier
block, and it's higher up.
And it's scarier. Right.
Three, two, one, pull.
I mean, it's not the most efficient way
of eating a Go-Gurt.
I definitely got some in my mouth there.
Oh man. I am covered.
Well, Dan, I would say my prediction
at the beginning of the
video is absolutely correct.
We did indeed make a right mess.
Of me. Yeah, you're fine.
It's ridiculous.
It's standard yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
You can get involved yourself
by showing us your best efforts
to get all the Go-Gur out of the tube.
Send your slomos to the
link in the description.
Cheers for watching.
You can follow us
on Twitter,
you can also buy one of our shirts.
Once again, you definitely
don't want Dan's shirt.
It's caked, but we have
some fresh clean ones
for you to purchase.
There's also a poster.
Have you seen it?
Yeah.
It's our massive mugs
on a poster.
There's Go-Gurt in my hair in that one.
So if you want Dan and I up on your wall,
sort of just looking
at you really close up,
get a poster for sure.